we got a [ __ ] Rock Monday right now and
I'm dead serious I want to thank the
people from West Palm Beach I want to
thank Florida for raining the whole time
I was there I want to thank you Brennan
for that goddamn Native American quilt
you're wearing things are called double
RL okay so it isn't cute it's a double
are else double I'm not giving that away
let me tell you something you buy this
about I spent some money on some jeans
double-arrow yeah now they're great
jeans but they ripped it off they ripped
in the knee and I think that was on
purpose but daddy's little tool to wear
something that can have the ribs dude
can't have the ribs
care the ribs can't put a fin on the
back here Honda Civic there are certain
things you can't do when you're at your
age Justin any have braces can't
abrasive seen braces on on a man of a
certain age Obama yeah a man of a
certain age can't wear a shirt open you
can't wear you can't wear super tight
jeans at a certain age you still can't
wear bracelets you know it surrounds
your necklace isn't cool on older guys
bracelets or their own bracelets I saw
as I sat next to a dude Krista who was
older than me he had the lids on his
eyes and he had a bead bracelet on and
he was a business guy wasn't he wasn't
dressed he wasn't dressed the normal way
he was just wearing beads around us and
I was like you might be because whenever
I see a guy like that whenever I see a
dude who's dressed normal but then he's
got a little something he's got like a
necklace with like a quartz or he's got
like a couple bracelets but he's dressed
like he sells insurance I go huh you
might be a [ __ ] druid you might be a
[ __ ] closet
man which you might maybe you won't be
you might be worshipping Satan when
you're off on your free towel or the
other thing is sometimes you that
businessman with like the turquoise
bracelet or one pinky do [ __ ] he [ __ ]
how dude I got five he's wearing it cuz
like his 18 year old sidepiece told me
he's a swinger it's what he is I just
[ __ ] up ton smells smells a little bit
like suntan oil from change this chest
even though he's 58 yeah works out like
a month [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah a little
stiff in the back cuz all that struggle
spray tan lifts weights but he doesn't
stretch so he's a little tight but his
dick works and he's dirty he's a guy
he's got get in your mud whistle all
right first place he goes at the mud
whistle all right dude
I'm just saying
it's like my buddy Jimmy Burke I said I
don't usually go and lick the butt and
he goes he goes you get a little [ __ ] on
your tongue [ __ ] so what ha shut up
he's shamed me I was like oh no I mean
see you little [ __ ] on your tongue yeah
he made me feel like such a loser dude
what do you think it was so good why do
you think your tongue points I was like
hey I'm eating hey you know it's nasty
think about Jimmy Burke eating some
girl's ass man that that giant man
Lobster
no way oh not not a hair doesn't have
eyebrows giant barely has any pubes he's
like a giant baby
oh god I'm heat Marius look at that
[ __ ] man she met that guy long time
longest neck of all time I'll lick your
ass holy where are your eyebrows Jimmy
look at you look at you with no lips
you look like you [ __ ] enough red
pickle you ready [ __ ] huh that's his
thing what's that some people that's the
thing
Jimmy was completely naked in his and
his buddy John goes you look like a red
bumpy pickle
put some clothes off yeah yeah he's the
best he's the best the best like your
[ __ ] dude yeah yeah I mean listen son
real tight man
some people are into it I I met a girl
in Florida yep right it's a hoist for
her tonight
well the dude there's two weirdest girls
there were two words things girls have
says one girl said my favorite thing is
to have my ass Hedon that was fine I was
like all right that's good
now yeah not not gonna do that probably
I don't know what's going on hot enough
um and then I've done another girl who's
from Colombia told me she wanted to
drink my blood so those are the two
things those are the two things where I
went well now I'm not sure what to do
now
I like that you're into me that much
that you want to drink my blood you want
to drink my blood that's intense did I
ever tell you that's right no I thought
it was this past weekend no no this was
a long time ago I just wanted just so
hot I just want to drink your blood
oh well listen mr. van Pierre a the odd
no not into it
impossibly hard dude what
hell yeah hair at least at least my
wrists that seems very dangerous the old
neck hole Mike
nekke pooja that that's a girl who's
into you freak afriad there are girls
who do that there are some girls that
want to be dominated like that my friend
has my friend said to me I don't even
know if I can say this but he said to me
he goes she's so into me no you don't
understand why she she I'm not gonna say
it down her mouth and stuff yeah yeah
you said it called the shower yeah some
girls dig that they're just in the being
like bleh like I love you so much that
I'll do I'll let you do that good girl
hey hey wait I'm sorry to bring it there
on the Hyundai but it is [ __ ] rock
Monday and we gotta get serious
I met chins lady is actually why I met
her before what is this guy's name
bitch's Lake a Greg no he brought her to
a Qin Ontario I'm so impressed
why impressed well I mean I'm glad
they're dating thank you I appreciate
what's it about this particular woman
that broke they've been friend your back
forty years oh we've been friends for 20
years Oh 20 years and then so you got it
you jump you bounced out of the friend
zone
yeah after tornado stuff to do how did
you do that did she get faked hit what
happened did you get the Brazilian booty
left yeah like to get questions you know
what I mean sometimes somebody will show
up you be like what happened there oh
it's like I just you know I grew into
myself yeah what would what made it go
over to the more romantic side well it's
a little bit tragic how it started
I'm I told you guys what happened yeah
oh yeah he wanted friend passed away
from you answer yes her man no that's
her sister's husband Oh older sister's
husband okay so you guys were there
crying yeah we were just around each
other more and more and there just
happened naturally yeah I'll tell you
what man sometimes like crying stuff it
all turned on oh you mean when a girl's
crying girls cry yeah well III my dick
is let's get all pouty yes dude yes
that's terrible stuff that happens and I
start it's not the time my actually I
was sick oh I never touched you cry be
like
oh man listen let me help ya I'm way to
make you feel the lips would be all full
she looked all the door oh [ __ ] man yeah
so you guys are like yup see around a
sad time and then would you guys just
hanging out a ton trying to like yeah
all our friends were together but then
meaner we're always like super close
anyways so just yeah it's happened
naturally and there's no way well you
know there's a there's a thing called
oxytocin which is a bonding chemical so
when you're under duress so soldiers and
war
athletes in competition your mother's
pregnant moms that's what the that's
what the child yeah it's the same
chemical it's created in times of great
stress competition wherever and that
creates bonds between people that's a
very deep on criminals in criminal gangs
if they're not sociopaths that tend to
be where they get they get tight your
point with fighting to it's like you you
know we even with Travis brown with all
the ill-will we had to each other bad
blood once you go through that
experience afterwards
we [ __ ] man want to back up for sex
well no you what are you talking why did
you want to come out now no but for
reals we were cool oh you weren't no
yeah
look you shake my hands I hear you
alright again yeah you shattered my lip
whatever oh yeah yeah man let's not even
even through that so that's where you
guys create this bond chin and then when
did but even then he has just hanging
out and then you're just like oh this is
crazy
oh oh I mean she's always she's always
thought about you know would it be like
today me I thought about that the same
with her yeah but we just you know we're
such close friends we never did anything
you do want to cross the line Korean
it's very it's very very conservative
culture right between men and women like
to third base for you is like touching
his well I'm glad you have a girlfriend
thanks man you deserve appreciate oh
wait you're be on your hands me I'm her
man a relief on both are in yeah yeah
what'd you do for Valentine's Day I hung
out with my friend Sabrina I
purposefully didn't want to hang out
with any dudes on Valentine's Day go
give him the wrong idea it I think it's
too much pressure to like a first day or
even like something relatively new like
I don't want to do it on Valentine's Day
you coulda came if you're just wanted
mean go awesome do
you came to my Ontario show it was
goodness so I could meet Chin's
girlfriend but then I ended up getting
stuck in a bunch of traffic I wasn't
gonna make it on time through that
Ontario Drive excuse me sir when I got
there I'd rather I gave me a little hot
I apologize the manager because how was
the driveway she's me sir here's how the
drive went I'd rather I'd rather do
shows in Florida and then fly back every
other to take the six-hour flight oh
dude
three hours that traffic each three
hours there Thursday three and 20
minutes Friday three hours and then two
hours on Saturday Wow it's simply too
far simply get better [ __ ] roads make
bigger roads no I don't care if you have
to kill mountain lions and deer I don't
want to sit in traffic like that God did
you know what I was looking for is like
a private jet or helicopter helicopter
Burbank Don [ __ ] helicopter will
truly be worth it I would do it I looked
for a helicopter and there's nothing
there was nothing at the time I mean I
don't know how much it would cost worth
it I know because you'd make it there
and what but then do you know James no I
don't want a helicopter safe empties
ninety-nine percent of time we're safe
of course Haggard that was fog
apparently yeah yeah mm-hmm that's like
that's like when you take when you go
from LaGuardia I'm sorry JFK to New York
City no you can sit in traffic for an
hour and a half and it's the worst kind
of traffic as the air so you know we're
getting a helicopter for nine minutes
for nine minutes and you're right there
I'm talent and you know how much it cost
200 bucks doing it no it's not their
firm they're doing it but where was the
picture bad not the airport yeah your
flight well you could say FK you could
have called blades it's a company you
get in the helicopter yeah so nine
minutes oh boy by the way who's your
cousin Jeff couple him crashed
yeah I bet they did they did but worth
it it's so worth the rest worth it roll
the dice rolling the dice oh your boy
was super sick on Friday and Jays
driving me how did you get sick what was
that that's not curled I do I mean when
you're not sleeping coronaviruses yeah
you have Koran oh that's good
I've been sleeping it's just the whole
the whole family's sick
Johanna was sick Tiger was sick bossy
not sick and I was the only one not oh
my god dude that I was like making fun
of them sure that's like a genetic thing
yeah then sure enough yep boys make you
know you're getting sick when Mexicans
get sick cuz they never get sick from
[ __ ] they said about Italians to the the
immigrants when when the Irish for them
they say you never see a sick Italian
because they just the way they would eat
compared to the lot of the other
tomatoes and vegetables and and taking
naps in the middle of the day and [ __ ]
those those cultures know how to how to
do it right and you know this
intermittent fasting it's so cracks me
up most of Europe like all of Italy was
will they do it never [ __ ] me they
never eat breakfast Middle East they
don't eat breakfast the Lebanese don't
eat breakfast it's lunch yeah but yeah
nobody's breakfast right if you go to
Italy you can specially southern Italy
they have one little espresso in the
morning that there are like espresso
bars they stand they have one tiny
espresso each like that and they go to
work there's no food that they might eat
a little bread but usually no and then
then lunch is good meal and then they
take a little nappy-poo oh dude cause
yes enjoy a siesta what so on board that
would laugh at this my my you know Jay
doesn't have any kids Jay was in town in
LA right he met I don't you met boss in
a while ago
already chosen brave that's lovely you
know whatever four or five months ago no
bosses only either way he's doing me at
the same time meeting them and I go he's
not good with babies and kids so you let
me get a picture and so I have the
picture I juice homies like real stiff
you don't know what to do with kids so I
take the picture I sent it to my dad and
my stepmom Deborah and they go man he
looks like a natural and I went you have
as natchez Elton John in a church I just
met you everybody
Papa was not having it really oh man I
mean I'm from 6-10 come on take a joke
but not not on this thread why well he's
in town on Friday what was wrong with
that I don't know about Church her but I
don't know he didn't like that I made
fun of Jay and the baby I don't know I
thought it's Larry wish J thought is
funny yeah the guy takes that not funny
I'm not having it not on this thread not
on this slip haven't heard from man all
right but then uh so Tigers birthday's
on Saturday and he wanted this car like
a like a like a jeep truck car right so
we ran off Amazon comes in 1000 piece oh
my god hey somebody I paid somebody to
assemble my bed so dude so I've left in
the guest bedroom I worded a month ago
because I wanted to sell out of who
knows so I got a month ago big box like
I don't know dude for huge like a big
box dude like two of these possum in
there so but Jay stay in the guest room
so I put it together last week right
Papa puts it together you get this truck
there I put this thing over it well Jade
no kids doesn't think of anything
well Tiger wants when he's up he and if
let's say you're there Jair he wants
them up when he gets up he wants them up
everybody's getting up everybody's
playing he's gonna get to 5:30 so I get
a fight I love getting up early so I get
up with Tiger but he goes let's go get
uncle Jay how didn't you think about it
you on my coffee tea you go wake up your
uncle what comes in there and then Tim
is there hair oh my god the truck comes
on is I feel big and burly big he's up I
didn't know you can't have that thing
I'm like [ __ ] dude
I went there's a blanket over he goes
why is there a blanket over a truck like
that's his birthday gift there's a
surprise goes I didn't know just that
today dude my girl was so kids I see you
got my truck let me have to give it to
of course you ladies just drive around
the house music oh when is it birthday
Friday but we're celebrating Saturday
what um what what was the thinking
behind the naming your son Boston well
what was that it was that a thing you
just like the name er yeah I just love
the name Boston Jay I don't know yeah
yeah I don't know it's good it's fair
enough yeah I don't know yeah it's
English yeah you know I don't know yeah
Brian Brian cross my mind
thank you you're their uncle
uncle bride now is a terrible name I
would have thought I would have been
like change his name immediately what
the Brian's a [ __ ] name I can't
stand that I I hey my dad hey Dad
number one don't name me Brian even
though your best friend's name was Brian
they'll put up to it back then though
yeah yeah but number two he decided to
name me Brian with a why cuz it's unique
because it's unique hey Dad
no the rest of my life I gotta go no
it's Brian with it you spell it with an
i it's a why bribry [ __ ] that dude
you're 53 let's change your name
I'd love to don't go by let me well man
dragging her ranks is my new name
[ __ ] my name is rinks thank you very
much rinks her man dragon rinks or gay
owl or [ __ ] you know I got we found a
street art art now dance
thanks to this [ __ ] podcast
[ __ ] man rings hey guys can't help it
today like hey rinks you sweet tart tart
nasty how will [ __ ] man dragon being
a blah blah blah thanks miss yeah all
right now guys all right you know it's
that it's incredible it's incredible
yeah would you do with your friend Kat
unbalanced do you guys just chill yeah
just walked around the beach chilled out
single girl now
yeah single girl because your friends
think you two huh your friends single
yes she's single come with barrels in
the 20s she's very single
she's very smooth miss is she black man
so cool yeah I think they're shocked a
lot that [ __ ] of the latter you took a
like that what does she do
um she's still student at USC a little
young for you
oh we held I think she's 21 got a great
night
you know man a pair bells do what your
sister do for Valentine's Day my sister
I have no idea actually
mmm I should ask her dude some well that
was a song what I was good like you I
was with Jay right we're like Chuck in
John I'm not feeling great we have to go
do this thing and then all right go pick
this thing about double RL and I'm like
God found things yeah you pick up
flowers we get to the house and then
dingdong there's a delivery what the
[ __ ] is that this this vase of flowers
from I don't know the Bellagio or Little
Caesars I don't who the [ __ ] sent it
it's again the vase sizes table 40
long-stem roses oh my gosh [ __ ] is this
man open up the card it says Happy
Valentines family Jay goes you bought
this at [ __ ] know that I'm already
nervous I sent a picture to join I go
hey the [ __ ] sent these Shaco that's our
florist because they messed up on these
other flowers so that's him trying to
make it up to us as well a lot of
flowers what but I was like how much
money do you spend at that florist it
was like [ __ ] dude
well I can't go to Ralph and get the
Bulls so now now your flowers gonna look
I need make they're gonna look like
skinny little [ __ ] compared to that
don't send my girl there you [ __ ] the
forest of red Rodya [ __ ] me dude a
forest [ __ ] me Jesus Christ I was seeing
a girl and and I came to her house and I
was like hmm is that 50 roses or that a
hundred so she goes it's a hundred I go
hmm who said that she goes it's just a
guy's a friend I go oh I see friends
that's interesting because it doesn't
feel that way then I called her and you
know somebody answers the phone but they
don't somehow the phone gets answered by
accident we mean well I don't know what
I mean but I just know let's say I
called I called and the phone was
answered so she might have like seen it
and she wasn't like whatever she was
coming screaming it off whatever it is I
just heard oh no I heard this I heard
this was the grand heart are you see my
shoes on shoes uh-huh
on the bed oh that was your girl oh I'm
a girl oh oh oh and girl that's I called
her up and I go I know I went over and I
go hey yeah cuz I don't for me if you
like that guy that's the truth I'm never
gonna I'm not gonna [ __ ] be like book
you cuz if you maybe like him maybe he's
better we can do you so I just thought I
might go so did you talk to her I find
so did you
dude your guy get his shoes cuz I know
they're on the bed it's like and she's
just not
I'm and it was a guy she had dated yeah
whatever I kept a cheat code you can do
if you're dating a girl or you wanna
know if she's seen other dudes you go to
the toilet man so you go to it you lift
the lid it's very rare the girl to clean
the lid guys piss on that toilet oh you
know what the best thing is I've never
done that huh it's retile it Chuck dude
I love that you just told me that I wish
I'd known that I mean lift that [ __ ]
lid and see who else has been pissing in
my territory
yep I'm like oh you know you've been see
no one lately no no no I was pissed all
over the lid ha girls not doing that how
come these pee on the [ __ ] yeah
that's interesting
I'm glad you told that it fellas yeah
there you go
I'm gonna [ __ ] check that out I will
always lift the lid now goddamn who else
would do it
some dude with a big old angry dick yeah
who's that like I just got any busting
your girl who's handle your daddy yeah
that [ __ ] skinny 53 year old [ __ ]
guy with a with a bank account of this
dude this for my shoulders and I serve
and I'm in my 20s sir I'm dude I'll tell
you what how about the white out in it
you definitely did it you don't watch
American Idol cat do you watch smirking
Idol no it's not a debuted got your boy
choked up really chin does garage or
garbage man do that I'm gonna go ahead
and pee out of my song I want to see
this oh there he is yeah let me sit I'll
set up for Brian what are the underwear
I always wear always me undies oh my god
that's right they retain their shape
they hold my package in place and that's
my package is pretty unruly dude your
ears Mines wiling out to the hey yeah
yeah yeah that's like a Hells Angel my
back yep yep of course he's he's I mean
yeah the oddness keeps him down keeps
him quiet cuz with the problem me unease
is made of more now it's such soft soft
and flexible material and it holds your
rump in place there's nothing like it
what else they got a Z yeah even they
have size XS which would be extra small
right yeah and then they have four XL
what bro oh they got a friend thick and
thicker I made with micromo down dude
it's a magical sustainable soft is
health fabric made from trees how crazy
is that
that's why your bits and pieces that's
where your three-piece set that's why
the baby bird feels like it's floating
on a cloud do you have a subscription
every month I get a free pair of undies
so do I go to my house babam what's up
they're the best the best me undies me
undo act facts and you guys get a great
offer for a first time purchasers you
get 50% off and free shipping
this is no-brainer especially cuz they
have a hundred percent satisfaction
guaranteed you get 50% off your first
pair of free shipping and all you got to
go to is me undies calm slash fighter
here's what's gonna happen beyond DS
calm slash fighter you'll have your
underwear on you but I don't like these
ones those are my own ones you'll always
try to wear those you'll have your
favorite undies me undies you guys want
a box of awesome huh
you are the best stuff ever sent to you
every month like it's a surprise I need
a bunch of random stuff all right how
about it have to be good all right we
got you got crazy stuff you got
champagne saber or perfectly aged winter
cocktails you got a box of awesome and
by real mean stuff that I would you got
styled you got wood you got grooming
goods you got barwary you got cooking
tools you got outdoor gear you got
whatever it is it's a surprise it's
stuff you didn't know you need but that
you need box of awesome calm they will
help you pick it too they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories it's free to sign
up but each box costs only 45 bucks but
has over $70 worth Wow
dude get off yes get those monthly box
when you sign up for box of awesome calm
and to the ghost fighter at checkout
that's box bounces back gap code fighter
for twice off your first box once a
Lululemon to buy socks and as I walked
in this really cute girl looked at me I
was going into the dressing room I was
gonna try on these [ __ ] pants these
ABC pants and she goes like this she
looks at me and she goes huh I walk into
the dressing room and she had floated a
whole bunch of air biscuits in there and
she was walked you walked away
double-time
with her back all stiff like please
don't say anything I was like I was like
well you know I got a I got a word I
mean just farting up a storm just but
Bravo biscuits but also don't go to
Lululemon you know that right no it
tried to a lot of Chico's yeah oh my god
I think the ones that work there I just
all [ __ ] athletes but uh yeah but I I
tried them pants a braid on me but
didn't buy him lose let me see this so
um yeah so he long story short
he's a garbage man out of Georgia has no
training whatsoever just sings he has a
daughter and wants to make a life for
his daughter so he decided to give it a
shot go ahead he says Rawls a gift just
play the part ways things are they're
told no Brian see the whole thing feel
all okay Jesus Christ so he has a
million views oh no I gotta get his
teeth gotta get his teeth great you tell
you this week a good show well I don't
reduce my body in great laughter after
what Luke Bryan does for this guy yeah I
was like five I've always liked Luke
Bryan but so fast forward because they
warm he goes warm
up in front of like a live crab oh wait
okay there you go 15 minutes later there
we go
h1 we go like I'd be nervous I'd be so
nervous I love this guy can play piano
on it yeah what he's he's so talented
of course he is he's one of my favorites
I don't know he is even Wow how cool is
that
Wow have you ever seen the lightning bug
house princess in the frog
yeah he's the lightning bug huh Prince
the Frog oh that's such a good what do
you mean a lightning just the way he
talks and yeah the way looks well listen
I mean in that cool he's like he like
you just fans like I seen you in the
back of my car you know when you try to
get a fake tooth that's $5,000 so there
are people that just don't have the
money and get it [ __ ] - though you
know 3,000 the $4,000 get a real implant
but how cool is there - Luke Bryant was
like no dude he's awesome he's the best
he's all these people are so special
there's a reason right there's a reason
at the Lionel Richie Luke Bryan um Kay
Perry would say what you will about a
pop music there's significant human
beings that and that success that I
don't have to say is but people think
sometimes it's an accident there's no
accident
these are quality [ __ ] Richie
are you like Ryan I mean Jin yeah I
don't even know him but I can just tell
but that little thing I might you've
heard some of his songs I'm sure has
some huge hits
what are the biggest what a powerful
music artists writing powerful big he's
pretty yeah it's so powerful and people
can sing like that I don't know what it
is music and I'm jittery emotion gets up
all of us emotional I was crying good
night
it gets off that one and then forget the
other one I personally yeah I personally
don't understand how you can't believe
in some kind of a god when you hear
music I'm serious I mean you know what
it does let me let me tell you something
so so this is what this is not my idea
this is show this is schopenhauer this
is nietzsche let me let me tell you
something most of us in life
we're driven by what's called a will to
live to pro to reproduce to eat sleep
eat sleep you know [ __ ] I mean that's
kind of what it is if you think about
everything we do is to support that and
to to
you know procreate and crate you know of
child children and that's a grind in its
own way right it's like we're working
and stuff like that and then when you're
making something like that or you're
listening to something like that what
happens when you want to cry like that
is you forget you forget about your
biology you forget about the fact that
you need sleep you forget about the fact
you need money you forget about your
bills everything stops and it's those
moments that is that moment of Arrested
Development that beautiful moment that's
why we stay alive for art and that's why
cultures don't identify if you ever
think about cultures they don't think
about how a culture identifies them they
don't identify with their banks and how
much money they make they identify with
their artistic expression and that's
that's what's so powerful you're like
that guy cards really important I think
that guy comes in has no clue what he's
doing you can tell he's just like your
average Joe
yeah but he's trying to intervene but he
doesn't know how is the idea he's
probably been singing like Ray
LaMontagne
he's probably been singing like that
forever
I think Adele was that way she was just
always singing even as a kid and they
just learned how to sing by singing all
the time
you know [ __ ] that's incredible I can't
help it oh that another kid who was
these parents were I forget where
they're from either Indian or feed your
son like that but they they laughed
right they had to get out of there for
some horrible reason they came to Kansas
City this kid gets on like well even
Luke Bryan was like yo I have a arena
next next week in Detroit would you want
to open for me
Wow I you might be able to find him it's
insane dude how old is it kid
18 yeah yes some people just have this
insane power
we're like what is going on man I know
this guy can stop it Gil carefully and
then hit it this guy him right there
first one yes from Nepal Nepal very poor
very poor
so watch this [ __ ] kid handsome kid
usually been there for five years
good-looking kid man Jesus Christ she is
this my favorite show no one's 18 I
don't watch that huh there's 18 whoa
what isn't it yummy so weird to me
now watch the notes the judges give him
notice his eyes and laughs yeah in it I
know what they really they know their
[ __ ] i watch whoa
Claire's clear Wow
not what a [ __ ] voice alamin look at
his look at his attitude since he opened
his eyes
yeah he's on it man yep he's connecting
and he's singing too he should use his
eyes he's got amazing eyes this is John
Fogerty this guy could write a song
Danielle Pam whoa how do you judge this
when eyes are all these talented people
how do you judge it'll get past the
Hollywood and then Hollywood they go
through certain phases and then you get
to the live the top 25 or whatever top
15 right and then it's America's job to
judge it but there's guys I kin like
he's not he's not like a pop star like
he's a straightening he just soul so he
might not win American Idol like last
year they had this kid I forget his name
remember I played him for you guys he
was really good on the gay i freed his
name he had o be huge
oh yes he didn't win he's [ __ ] here
I'd listen this day his band's called
like the like the pink now he cares
there's also there's this one huge it's
one thing that's sing somebody else's
songs it's not anything to write your
own songs and that's where the big
challenge comes mm-hmm there's people on
here I bet they do they sing original
songs and Katy Perry and Lionel Richie's
like holy [ __ ]
let's say Allah Hanzo good for him dude
I'm I don't know why I don't watch the
show I can used YouTube this whenever
you want and you just watch all totally
not no no come fox o or ABC so you know
all the Honjo is like selling out
everywhere Nelly but he's not he's not
like he's not gonna fit the American
Idol narrative we'd like this pop
he's like he creates his own [ __ ] his
own music he puts his own spin on things
he's huge he's huge man I'd love to be
able to play the piano or the guitar I
got signed up for piano lessons when I
was 14 years old and I said no and I
[ __ ] should have done it I played
piano for a year we're not why not dude
but then again my my yes Terri pool
party that's their names my co-star
Brett Dyer could just play the [ __ ] out
of a piano he's plays it's a pretty cool
thing that you ought to do and what's so
he's like you're not not your
conventional like artists and so by him
going on American Idol now you have all
the guys like the last look at all
they're coming on there now because I go
[ __ ] you don't have to be like a
straight pop like Katy Perry style you
can be like a normal musician so you
like because of him all these like kind
of weird different voices on American
Idol now it's really cool yeah look at
that dude doing the damn thing look a
Fram yeah man what can you do that's
sick cool it's so cool I don't know are
you uh can I can I can I get a
prediction for you from from you for
this fight Saturday here which one wild
of fury uh I think while it gets done
you do mmm
me too I do too have a weird feeling I
hate Bennigan's fury Furies awesome but
Wilder I feel is getting better and
better
his older Wilder is mm-hmm 36 he's 36
he's 30 series younger you're saying 32
hmm it's just that while there aren't
that devastating whatever it is I don't
know what do you think you think louder
gets it done knock out yeah cuz you
can't make mistake here he hasn't looked
that good as last two outings yeah
you can't make a mistake with that but -
fear - are you for a fury there like
when he fought Wilder did he should not
been fighting them maybe he took it too
soon he like came back after that Shuri
out or sure he fought like two straight
bums and then [ __ ] Wilder yeah and
then really beat him 10 out of 12 right
yes he did so yes he did was able to
stay out but he has a new trainer you've
got rid of that
Ben Davidson I thought did a great job
is this new trainer it's coming in that
heavy which I don't thinks he's coming
in heavy he wants get heavy and thinks
he's gonna knock Wilder out huh I don't
like hearing that stuff yeah I mean he's
such a good skill talk sir you have no
skill yes in the world
his ability yes sure by far his ability
how would he have done against Klitschko
and and those guys you'd beetle he would
have beat him right I think so too
so skill so skilled you can't hit him
his ability is moving oh I don't like
this killing heavier I like his last two
outings I don't know man
he's my favorite that's a conscious
decision to come in heavier yep
it's team want to come to heavier is
that muscle weight weightlifting so big
who knows yeah yeah just want to just
fight like you know ton of coverage is
it no it's not it's weird it's really
weird
we haven't UFC step long not this
weekend nothing that you know should
cover yeah Paul fell just fighting down
hooker okay Kurt event see some current
events sounds good when you're selling
online
get yours out can be a pain in the neck
daddy keep track of who gets what which
shipping carriers should use are you
getting the best rates all these
questions here's here's here where the
answers lie ship station cop yes this
easiest most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders just a few clicks
and you'll be managing your orders
printing out labels getting your
products out fast to keep your customers
have made ship HAP [ __ ] station makes it
easy do know what you could ship me some
energy well well listen you're tired
right now I start talking about ship
station is just so easy I save energy
yeah what you're selling Amazon Etsy
your own website ship station brings all
your orders into one simple interface
making them really easy to manage from
any device even and so order your cell
phone dude words they work with all the
major carriers UPS FEDEX namely yes even
I mean even even Amazon okay UPS USPS I
meant okay name anyone they work with
right now fire routed Lister's can try
ship station
for sixty days when you use the offer
code Fighter 3 it's absolutely no risk
and start your free trial without even
entering your credit card
just visit shipstation comm click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in fighter that shipstation comm
that enter code fine air should stay
calm make ship happen
Keats I want to talk to you about
Keith's bars their key to friendly they
are delicious and they're made with
whole ingredients like almonds they had
absolutely no sugar no sugar v with
fda-approved keto sugar replacement out
yours how about the entirely plant-based
yeah clothes clean keto how about that
Stevie blue eyes can't eat them his girl
can eat them everybody yes
he eats calm / fighter try the bars how
about I shove a couple chocolate chip
cookie dough in your stupid mouth do it
and you know what oh you know I'll do oh
go to Keep Calm / fighter try Keith's
bars for free that's right three bars
with free shipping key eats calm /
fighter kernels do some carrot too old
for American Idol
I just stopped watching after a while
now I'm saying to participate I think so
even when I first saw it I was told they
did have an age limit back then or if it
still sold today yeah that about cut you
know that age limits why would they do
that they wanted young you know they
wanted young pop stars for sure yeah I
did do a start star searched when they
returned I did audition for that you
didn't make it
I [ __ ] up I forgot the lyrics and then
I walked away oh I was so confident I
was so confident I drank like crazy the
night before and I was just like I'll
kill this and I didn't prepare it's like
one of the very few times I didn't
prepare yes like way overconfident and
all it got the little 327 maybe and was
uh Ed McMahon still the know they did a
reboot they did a reboot the home back I
forgot it was like three people I think
that's right
and so you tried out for I just did it
in front of a huge audience to enormous
audience then the majority the audience
were a pee
whatever contestants that were
auditioning for this for the show and
then they had this huge camera when the
red light came on they go you know you
know and they say we could use this for
anything so all that was in my head
forgot the lyrics I go I'm messed up P
socked away you didn't try again I did
it I tried it again I've messed up the
lyric again I was like dude it was
embarrassing but then it taught me a big
lesson see like prepare and don't be
overeager
yeah don't be overconfident you know I
had a guy I did an audition one time and
the famous a famous director and he said
I did it and he goes can you do me a
favor and he goes can you go outside and
just come back in one minute I was like
okay I came back one minute he goes now
I want you to do the exact same thing
but I want you to sit down
mmm I was like where he goes on the
floor he didn't want me to move and he
just had me talk to him directly it was
really an interesting experience and
then that he wanted me for the part but
the network was like Matt who the [ __ ]
was it famous director but I was like
this is gonna be weird so I was on the
floor in front of them I was like forget
you know my line no I just was doing he
said I don't know sometimes sex doesn't
make you do weird [ __ ] like that
yeah the guy off because I was [ __ ] up
in the beginning and then he made me go
back outside do it again do it again
one time I said can I do it again I
think I heard the guy a big producer
goes we're good all right well cool all
right that's not gonna go my way this
are you shooting no we're not Brennan
we've got three more episodes to go
three more episodes to go so this was
submitted by Magic Mike smalls on
Instagram right so lately Crocs have
been doing a lot of collabs with a lot
of different people they did one with
post Malone that sold out and now
they're doing one with KFC donuts coming
in the spring of 2020 where's that girl
cross hug that's the commercial right
yeah it's the commercial and they're
coming out with the little giblets the
little charms in the shape of fried
chicken pieces don't want in on this
that's interesting
I'm not a Crocs guy me neither I hate to
show the hon sexy they are comfortable
slime come if you leave the house with
them I don't take you service is so easy
to wear
I bite I'm not being a dick you know if
you wore Crocs to this studio yeah I
swear on my life what and I've never hit
you like Haley hit you yeah I will hit
you where I'm gonna beat you all over
your body hold on hi this is a free
country what are you talking about yours
free it's free would you would you like
I'm allowed to do whatever I wanted
would you do it with an open hand open
closed my spikes should you just get me
hot around look he's right walk-in with
Crocs and you give me a you give me a
beat around or fighting on sight but I'm
gay you've been warned so not wrestling
just gonna you gonna that that that you
have for me huh get you up you might
piece me up a little [ __ ] you up like
old school worldstar fight video I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up I gotta roll I got I
got a ball up and come at you whatever
you want to do yeah if you wear Crocs
we're fighting on site you start kicking
hitting me punching me out my elbows in
the move you can't just dig to the body
I can hurt me nope name a move hit me in
the face no I'm really a [ __ ] up
really be no no I don't like this yeah I
don't like this man oh don't wear Crocs
this all right now I feel like I'm
you're you're you're bullying me intend
gonna have into my shoe where I don't
have to do but but what if somebody buys
them for me and I wanna I'm feeling
comfy that [ __ ] don't wear him here I
wanna beat you up you can't do that the
only time I put my actual hands on you
you put hands on me
but all up on you dude that's not
exactly would take the croc and rip them
like this so now you sent me out all
beat up and bruised with no feet or no
shoes that's super insulting dude you've
been warned so I got a pad out with my
bare feet nothing I hate more than crime
with a concussion and maybe a little
blood in my lip hate him - you got so a
youtuber named Natalia Taylor she did a
video and on her Instagram prank where
she basically went to Ikea took a bunch
of photos and posted them onto Instagram
that she was in Bali and she wanted to
see how many people would be able to
catch that she's in an Ikea and she's
not actually in Bali no I love her and
you can see basically in the background
like you see the little tags you see
other people just sitting chilling
around and she didn't explain what was
happening on her Instagram but she made
a whole youtube video about it basically
doing she - yeah like she brought her
photographer and she was just like don't
believe everything you see on the
internet that's so so good that's her
video no this is someone else
that's a guy yeah that is a guy with
great eyebrows oh [ __ ] kiss hi guys girl
that's so funny
don't believe everything see on the
ground who does believe everything this
feeling right how do you make things I
never made any of it how many followers
does she have three hundred and twelve
thousand more now Oh cute very cute just
a little thing oh I want to start doing
that I'm gonna pose with a bunch of
stuffed animals you should tell me - we
should have done that be yeah oh that's
another one of the photos her in the
bathtub that's hilarious
that's a key huh yeah that's at IKEA oh
honey where should i travel to next
that's really good you should travel to
my instant I gotta travel to my heart
she's smart she's gorgeous and she's
smart mm-hmm oh boy roulette explain she
looks very young yeah well um what i
what i I I know some some young men who
are comics maybe who will hit up
Instagram girls on Instagram and then
what you see on Instagram versus what
you say real life I guess there's
something called a filter oh yeah that
old riders know about little catfishing
it's a catfish situation
it's the filter fishing you know yeah
well guys will be like the funk I'm
gonna run away and you know I wrong she
does not look like we know who came the
ontero steaming his girl oh really med
at MIT MIT the lady fantastic she's
something else
oh yeah they call
don't kid yourself it's a beautiful I
ask this from a different plan that
that's right that's right
Chiana what Steve you what are we doing
what are we doing do I know he's sure to
do he's doing I know
don't distract me with it Oh what are
you doing you make me Nikken my wheeze
yeah she's so hot I told her I was gonna
go vegan she's vegan as a cop I'm going
V you know whatever you gotta get
whatever dude is that what Stevie said
to you and hey see ya she does go via
dialog right we're friends I mean is
there anything you know what I mean
you're my show you don't pay for tickets
maybe we all shake it up shake it shake
I'm great the holiday I didn't think of
one thing yeah I feel better than they
have a jacuzzi it's a public one but I
figure it out you're right dude I
slipped the security guard a couple
extra bucks to make it private all right
what else you got
so did you guys see Chaka Khan's
national anthem from Atlanta I didn't
but did you see Jennifer Hudson's yes so
good with Kobe Bryant was Selma taking
this no I'd like her to cry old [ __ ]
yeah cuz I love John Watson and she
can't sir sir sir sir sir Sir sir bring
that up so cachaca condo
yeah sure Concord seen 40 years ago she
did a really questionable rendition and
people are comparing it to Fergie's oh
you watch this one first or you want to
watch it now I wanna see this one's
probably let's see Jennifer she can sing
oh yeah she's incredible how long is
this Jude
five minutes 54 so you watch whole thing
and now you get the idea though yeah I
mean you did you get better voice is the
voice get effortless absolutely it's so
crazy so good the so crazy so she that
was dope but did the Hofstra game they
just did it right because the pro ball
and then FL sucks [ __ ] but this NBA
all-star game was so good
yeah then that was on a court she did
that right on the court yes help the
taupe in it but then they did open it
with common and him doing you how does
his power like speech I don't know if
that is it's Chicago and he goes through
all the Great's of Chicago they have
this little boy they're like dreaming oh
my god and then he introduces the
starting lineup let me see that it's the
best all-star Pro Bowl you know I'm
gonna happen every time now let me let
me go ahead and see some of that have it
somewhere here common well someone said
it was funny on Barstow how I introduce
all the names I thought it was dealt oh
no no this is just him but it's the
lead-up that's a dope if you steal
common all-star game intro on YouTube so
good this city could talk Oh humanity at
his best humanity at his best
[Music]
it's long like humanity at its best is
it's like transcendence about shut up
you shut up there's something
transcendent about that [ __ ] is that's
cool that's that's where human beings
are way more than just animals it's a
fundamental difference consciousness
artistic expression things that make you
believe that anything is possible all
that stuff inspiration ladies and
gentlemen inspiration give me out of
here you guys one watch the Chaka Khan
part no uh-huh to inspire now I wants
the old what you think was gonna happen
you know she's still awesome alright I
had this ready last week but we didn't
talk about it
Rebecca Black you know a song Friday it
was like the most famous song for the
worst reasons cuz it's so cheesy
no how does she's a little girl it's
Friday Friday something goes down on
Friday
you wanna hear real quick scene
and all the song yes how the [ __ ] do you
know we actually played it on this
podcast a long time right really it was
embarrassed though showed it to me all
these views we can't really play on our
episode obviously and I'll paraphrase
and I'll play for you guys and you can
be act I think your parents are rich and
they pay holy [ __ ] as 1.1 million lights
3.6 million dislikes I've never heard
the song in my life enjoy
I think its finances she's rich and it
was just good course she's only 13 by
the way she's trying mm-hmm if I show
this [ __ ] I did when I was in my 20s it
was a it was unwatchable yes yeah it was
like it's really really bad and she
became famous for it because it was so
bad oh right that was when she was 13
okay how old she know
so she's 22 now and this is a reason why
I brought this up mom so she wrote to
herself like she wrote a post saying
like if I could tell my 13 year old self
how you know you should be proud of this
and that she's like cuz she was after
this video came out she was bullied suck
she's 13 you [ __ ] [ __ ] but also
anyone writing a song trying to do
anything creative faith on it unless
you're another creative you don't get a
say yeah she was also just posting
videos online at 13 for fun it just so
happened to him I had gone viral No okay
so wanted to be really good at 13 okay
so this is just her writing you know she
could make herself feel better when she
was a little kid she would but this is
her now whoa
right I knew it I how in the world I
could have caused oh my god what you did
is you bullied her into straight fire
right now she's fired
she's a girl what's up with Friday let
me go ahead and see good Lauren I knew
back you got a set of tits look at it
she's just really pretty she's cute
she's a killer
I mean my fan
good make fun of her now y'all yeah and
who wins now What's Up now [ __ ] well
that keep going go that was what the
[ __ ] is going on here daddy's
look and he's all like in yeah she's in
LA huh
I would imagine she's all woman it shows
her location chin I mean she's in my la
there yeah [ __ ] probably does looking
at other profiles all silver like come
on did he's beautiful she's gorgeous
I knew it was either one way or the
other she's gonna be on 609 for shooting
me just a smoke show yeah she's a she
wants moksha smoke sure she is she loses
she wins she she's guest of the year
yeah she's guest here so far she's in
the running for guests of the year those
kids are definitely just listen man
I call those tits possibility whoa I
mean it's like she's just outstanding
imagine fear this guy losers under that
magic for this Geico suit should I take
question mark Kaneko well yeah god Liam
yeah anyhow it's it's a happy ending
she's just working with a lot there oh
yeah so many tools
yeah we just lot going on so it's kind
of followers since just undeniable yeah
I appreciate more fathers initiator
instead of tits dude I swear to god I'm
about to about to god she's delicious
great kinda bad guys mmm-hmm
congratulations nothing but hot chicks
man let me fantastic Christ where's that
Runyan fry me whoopsie on their growth
something she should know they take it a
[ __ ] looks like Marlo is taking a [ __ ]
not pictured Marlo taking a huge [ __ ]
sorry oh well fine cuz we both had the
same tango eyes - [ __ ]
we're laughing at it of course we had to
say that of course poopoo had to come in
well though please start out with so
funny that was her caption not pictured
Marlowe
thinking yeah [ __ ] that would be the
funniest post she give my dog Turkish
[ __ ] oh my god
- on the plane today on the plane today
Delta I'm coming back from Atlanta and
the service dog took a giant [ __ ] and
the reason I know that is because a guy
how many hands said bryan callen and a
service dog i might buy my flight
kids screaming and kicking my seat Bryan
Callen and a service dog that took a
huge look a huge [ __ ] and they dead
masked people running back and forth
that became a huge problem because it
was probably a run I beat the shoes and
there you go took a [ __ ] you she's
delicious right you know what some more
all right this is just a sequence of
some get any more tips and shits God
celebrities I recently began tattoos on
their faces right so the first one Amber
Rose disappointing those are kids names
she's still pretty why would she do that
why in the world won't do that super
smart but what what is uh it's her two
sons names why would he do that does a
passion and slash on her head on her
head she like actually did an interview
where she she basically said that after
Kobe died she realized that life is
short and that she should do what she
wants oh you're still gonna be on the
planet for another I don't know 50 years
we're going to [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna
put you think Kobe you'd want that yeah
not about your kisses it's more about
you isn't it when you do that you have
anything embarrassing your kids so there
you go let's go ahead and see her what
she looks like nowadays so cuz I'm happy
with it
have you ever seen in person no really
she was a stripper right bring her up
really you don't say oh no that's not
her pregnant oh don't click are there
either how about that when she went
chocolate I know weird that's by China
yes black China
that kind of seems well-adjusted they're
tier now is that what she used to look
like this is her right here that's Chloe
right yes yeah well oh there she is
there's like her take that for a spin B
yeah I'm not matter
there's been a few rappers have busted
with that yeah that was a few yeah she a
white girl or she mix what is she I
believe she's Creole well there you go
grill well I appreciate it Creole yeah I
mean she's a big girl
don't is that her boyfriend that that
dude that's nice of you can't come to
her life you can't come to her life yeah
you're too light B yeah you gotta come
beliefe but that is wiz khalifa sheikha
on the warhammer lungs it makes noise I
think you can feed a cop cause oh yeah I
think a [ __ ] that thing's gotta be
rules yep what else you got yes she's
all just a few others so this is Chris
Brown he had a Nike Jordan Jordan tattoo
on his face what are you doing he's such
a good looking right now what do you
think I'm a sneaker head but unless
Jordans pay me a billion dollars a year
I'd like you know why are you getting a
[ __ ] sneaker on your face everyone's
doing it and then you're a girl Cindy
Crawford her son this is a model he got
a tattoo oh but he got misunderstood no
no food on his cheek
that's what this kid that's Cindy
Crawford's son mm-hmm do think about
when you're 45 and your face that's
misunderstood your kids like dad what
happened
good-looking kid billionaire well he's
not billing no daddy is what well bit
he's definitely not and there's gonna be
some issues there yeah no that's this is
statement if I thought this was going to
ruin my face or I didn't want this I
wouldn't have done it I think that's a
pretty obvious thing and then he goes
okay I love it by the way look at these
[ __ ] haters out here [ __ ] you if you
don't like it I mean it is his choice if
he wants to do it you think it looks
good yes I won't even cross my mind I
leave this studio I'm saying you [ __ ]
up looking kid this is a model what does
not mean what you can't huh all right
yeah on the face dude yeah I've never
got I don't get it
crow is it Elizabeth Hurley who has the
the son who he looks like a girl yeah
very pretty pretty who's this remember
Elizabeth Hurley sorry yeah that's a
pretty fella mm-hmm all right well
whatever I do blue gets get more choice
bro no that's it I do understand you
know should I gotta get my dates out yep
I'm I'm an Omaha I'm an Omaha Nebraska
the 28th and 29th of this month and I'm
sorry it's not on the website oh ma
we've already sold out one show there
are four shows friday saturday 28th 29th
saturday wanted i think one of the show
Saturdays already sold out get your
tickets
t f-- @k dot-com in vancouver friday
vogue theater that one show only vogue
theater Vancouver Just for Laughs comedy
festival next week Tacoma February 27th
through the 29th the March egg on this
theater run each city one show one night
only Atlanta March 13th New Orleans
March 14th
Toronto March 26 Detroit March 27th
Minneapolis March 28th and then and
let's see in April that's when we're in
Ireland Belfast the UK Newcastle Dublin
Manchester
Londyn you see it it's all there tik
calm but I will see you this Friday
Vancouver and Tacoma next week
let it be get that tooth out our faces
just all right this is the final kid
route